a Colorado man accused of murdering his
family is expected to be formally
charged today police arrested 33 year
old Chris Watts last week on suspicion
of killing his pregnant wife and two
young daughters autopsies were completed
but officials have not revealed a cause
of death or motive
Omar Villafranca is outside the weld
County Courthouse in Greeley Colorado on
mark good morning
good morning Chris watts is in jail but
formal murder charges are expected to be
filed in court today now his wife
Shannon Watson was pregnant and she was
supposed to have a gender-reveal party
this past weekend but instead her family
is planning a funeral hey guys I'm here
with my little munchkins hi for those
who knew Shannon watts and her daughters
Bella and Celeste the unanswered
questions are almost as painful as the
grief the hardest part about it all is
when you're closer with the family it's
the why Chris Watts remains locked up in
protective custody accused of murdering
his pregnant wife and two young
daughters
the girls bodies were found on a
property where their father worked
submerged for days and storage tanks
filled with crude oil court documents
filed by watts attorney suggested girls
may have been strangled the defense
asked the judge to take a DNA swab of
the necks on the remains of the two
children the judge granted that motion
but denied a request for a defense
expert to collect their own DNA samples
from the hands and nails of the mother
and children he's the best thing that
has ever happened to me Shannon first
met her husband after a mutual friend
connected them on Facebook court
documents showed the couple recently
struggled with debt filing for
bankruptcy in 2015 over the weekend
Shannon's brother took to Facebook
writing I've never been so mad sad
enraged hurt heartbroken lost and
shocked in all my life the family's
friends and neighbors are also still
trying to come to grips with the tragedy
it's too close to home it's
heartbreaking that's heartbreaking
Watts is due in court again tomorrow the
big question in this case is why and we
could learn that why today if the judge
decides to unseal the affidavit Nora
everyone asking that same question no
more thank you